my name is Daniel Goldman I'm associate
professor of physics at Georgia Tech and
my group is interested in how complex
behavior can emerge from the
interactions of many simple agents or
elements working together and in our
group we're taking what we call a robo
physics approach where robotics meets
physics thinking and we're creating very
simple but controllable little robots
smart active particles or smarta khals
as we call them and studying how changes
in their interaction properties lead to
group level behaviors we find that in
fact if we shine a light on some of
these some articles each happens to be
light-sensitive we can actually steer
the collective without the ability for
any one of the smart achill x' to move
on its own one of the problems we're
interested in is how a group of smarta
khals neither none of which can move on
its own can actually come together to
form an entity which can move across a
table so what are the rules and what are
the programs one would write to tell a
group of smarta khals to come together
to move across the table or to come
together to bunch up this is really an
intersection and a new intersection of
physics active matter physics and
computer science